هناك الكثير من القتلى هناك وهناك
بقي الكثير من الناس
أقارب مكثوا هنا لقضاء
عشية عيد الميلاد معهم وهناك الكثير و
حفيداتي هناك الكثير من الناس
داخل أن هناك الكثير من القتلى وذاك
لديهم ملاجئ دخلوا إليها
مع البنادق الطويلة وكل شيء ولكن ماذا
أطلقوا النار على الجميع هنا
قتلوا العديد من الأوصياء
لست بحاجة إلى معرفة ما يخبرونني به عني
إردا
سوف نعود
بعض الشيء
حسنًا ، أحدهم معتاد على ذلك ، لا أعتقد ذلك
لأنهم فعلوا ذلك بالفعل عدة مرات
الأشياء ، لكن كيف أطلقت عليهم النار؟
الناس نعم نعم نعم نعم كنت خائفة لأنهم
كان فارغًا تمامًا
[موسيقى]
العجز لأننا لا نستطيع فعل أي شيء
أي أنهم لا يفعلون شيئًا مع أقل من ذلك
ولا يمكنه فعل أي شيء وليس لدينا
لا أخبار من أولئك الموجودين هناك
بالداخل أو لا شيء